ali b ist zurück in deutschland der mann
der die 14 jährige susanna aus mainz
vergewaltigt und getötet haben soll
wurde am samstag aus dem irak nach
deutschland überstellt nach der landung
am flughafen frankfurt brachten schwer
bewaffnete sicherheitskräfte den 20
jährigen mit einem hubschrauber zum
polizeipräsidium nach wiesbaden
laut staatsanwaltschaft sollten dort
eine erkennungsdienstliche behandlung
und weitere polizeiliche maßnahmen
erfolgen
am sonntag soll bei der
ermittlungsrichterin in wiesbaden
vorgeführt werden b war nach angaben der
ermittler am frühen freitagmorgen im
nord irak festgenommen worden
der polizeichef der nordirakischen stadt
dohuk tarek amet sagte der verdächtige
habe die tat gestanden
b habe erklärt susanna seine freundin
von ihm gewesen
sie haben einen ausflug in den wald
gemacht und dort viel alkohol getrunken
und drogen genommen
dann kam es zum streit und susanna
versuchte die polizei zu rufen
der verdächtige bekam es mit der angst
zu tun weil sie unter 18 ist oder wusste
dass es eine schwerwiegende anklage
geben würde wenn die polizei käme er
versuchte sie zu überzeugen nicht die
polizei zu rufen
aber sie beharrte darauf daher erwürgte
er sie und begrub sie im dreck
laut einem medienbericht gelangen den
kurdischen sicherheitsbehörden im irak
der zugriff in letzter sekunde
bundespolizei chef dieter homann sagte
der bild abb habe sich noch aus dem irak
absetzen wollen am rande des g7 gipfels
in kanada sagte bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel
der mord habe ganz deutschland und auch
sie tief erschüttert ein solch
abscheuliches vorkommen ist sei für
viele menschen ein grund für große
sorgen
wir leiden mit der familie auf der
anderen seite ist das eine aufforderung
an alle erstens die integration sehr
ernst zu nehmen unsere werte auch immer
wieder deutlich zu machen aber eben auch
jede straftat zu ahnden entsprechend
recht und gesetz wir können nur
zusammenleben wenn wir uns gemeinsam an
unsere gesetze halten alibi lebt in
einem wiesbadener flüchtlingsheim sein
asylantrag war im dezember 2016
abgelehnt worden wogegen er klagte gegen
ihn laufen mehrere verfahren unter
anderem wegen des verdachts auf raub
bevor er zur fahndung ausgeschrieben
wurde setzte er sich mit seiner
familie in den nordirak ab der fall
löste in deutschland eine neue debatte
über die beschleunigung der
asylverfahren aus in mainz fanden am
wochenende demonstrationen zum fall
susanne stadt unter anderem eine
mahnwache der afd
aber auch eine gegenkundgebung der
antifa